alors on va parler évidemment de notre
dame c'est très simplement qu'on va
commencer cette émission à vous
demandant aux uns et aux autres ce que
notre dame représente pour vous quelle a
été votre réaction comme tout le monde
lorsque vous avez découvert les images
que la cathédrale en feu hier soir avant
d'en parler je vous propose d'écouter un
commentaire parmi d'autres c'est celui
de valérie précresse qui préside la
région ile de france
j'ai depuis l'adolescence un amour
passionné de notre dame pour moi c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une église c'est c'est
la beauté inouïe de paris c'est c'est
aussi la france l'âme de la france et
donc et donc voir brûler cette
cathédrale que j'aime ton et bien ça ça
m'a fait comme à des millions de
français je pense un immense choc pour
moi c'est beaucoup plus qu'une église
dit valérie pécresse pour vous c'est
quoi notre dame ce qu'on appelle un
symbole multiples moi je comment vous
dire moi je suis né à paris donc c'est
évidemment quelque chose que j'ai vue
inconsciemment veut de mes premiers mois
mais aussi c'est sait beaucoup de choses
c'est proust qui découvre la beauté à
travers notre dame de paris c'est c'est
un historien qu'elle j'ai consacré ma
thèse qui parle de la sensation
historique c'est ça en fait qui m'a le
plus touché c'est cette sensation
historique que j'éprouve et toujours
c'est à dire qu'en allant à notre dame
particulièrement en regardant les
rosaces pas tellement la façade qui a
été vous avez fait des fêtes refaite
mais les rosaces je me disais toujours
mais c'est l'intuition absolue du temps
c'est à dire ces écoliers de saphir
d'émeraude qui ont l'air de venir du
fond des âges et je me disais l'arl je
crois que je suis un peu devenu
historien notre dame de paris aussi le
temps qu'est ce que ça vous évoque pour
vous notre dame premier valérie blais
parler de l'adolescence et moi justement
je suis parisienne d'adoption puisque je
suis arrivé à l'adolescence à paris et
moi aussi j'ai passé des heures à
notre-dame
moi je suis d'une famille athée depuis
trois générations
pas baptisé depuis trois générations
militants laïques et j'ai toujours adoré
les églises
ma mère m'a transmis son amour du dollar
au mans mais également d'exotique donc
mais pour moi justement notre dame sait
c'est toute la culture occidentale
c'est à la fois le corps et l'esprit
c'est le savoir-faire des compagnons et
c'est l'élévation
alors pour moi c'est pas l'élévation
vers dieu mais c'est la dimension
métaphysique que j'ai en moi qui l
élévation de soit allé au delà de soi
même et aussi quelque chose comme
ben s'est levé et communier avec le tout
donc voilà donc c'est j'ai été
extrêmement ému hier soir et je dois
dire je le suis encore maintenant c'est
l'émotion aussi qui vous a gagné hier
soir olivier duhamel c'est l'histoire ce
que ça représente les siècles ce soit
présente
oui je le dirai peut-être l'occasion de
la discussion tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi quelque chose de personnel
il ya près de 50 ans j'habitais juste à
côté rue de bièvre depuis dix ans j
habite à nouveau mais hier soir je
n'étais pas là j'étais dans le sud donc
j'ai vu ça j'ai fini par les marchés
vers minuit 1h du matin parce que mon
fils veillée était chargé de me prévenir
et voilà ce que j'aime les envies d'être
apparaît dans ces cas là tu connais
absolument et alors voilà ce que j'ai
mis sur instagram des mines ils
n'étaient que quadragénaire mon oncle et
ma tante mon père ma mère il savait que
j'arrivais ces dernières années et que
se résorbait sa mobilité il choisir de
vivre ensemble dans une petite maison
quai de la tournelle pour voir chaque
jour notre dame si belle et maintenant
il ya une devant cette maison il ya une
petite passe qui s'appelle place jacques
duhamel juste devant notre dame
donc vous comprenez que je vous
répondrais politiquement mecs sont
d'abord ses liens personnels assez
étrange et puissant je précise que ma
mère était catholique est très croyante
mon oncle était juif mais aline au stick
ma tante était catholique aussi croyante
et mon père est écrite olic devenu alnot
stick après la mort de son fils donc
vous avez ils avaient tous un rapport à
la religion et à dieu absolument
différent c'est pour ça que votre
témoignage est aussi important mais
voilà notre lame transcende tout ça de
tous les points de vue à damas alexis
voudrais vous nous parler peut-être un
peu de la mobilisation figaro parce que
finalement dès hier soir tout le monde
était sur le pont ce que les autres
c'est fou comment on fait les mémoires
sont marqués par ce type d'événement et
10 ans 20 ans 30 ans après on se
souvient du jour où est par exemple il
ya des gens qui se souviennent de
l'assassinât de kennedy
je ne me souviens pas je me suis très
fière du 11 septembre on était au figaro
rue du louvre et je me vois très bien
dans le bureau où on a vu sur les télés
le la première tours qui s'effondrent
et puis la première tour qui s'effondre
à nouveau en dise pas possible et puis
en fait ce n'était pas la première
c'était une autre et je me revois rue du
louvre ça et hier soir je suis sûr que
dans 20 ans je l'aurais pas ou plus si
je suis encore en vie je l'aurais pas
oubliée
c'est à dire que moi j'étais dans mon
bureau en train tranquillement de faire
mon édito sur ce cas les dires macron
parce que dans ce métier on peut les y
tôt avoir maison il parle et puis
apprend les âges histoires d'animaux ce
que vous pensez des retraités cgt entend
travailler puisque et ses histoires
coeur nos mots qui m'a dit t'as vu ce
qui se passe et j'avais bfm l'un qui
tournait mais j'avais pas milson je dis
non et je regarde et je vois grand dam
en flammes et en cas de seconde
on comprend que se sont ils plus
question de macron qu'il est plus
question d'un truc et on attend le
moment où macron va dire valeur yart
qu'il reporte et il met un peu de temps
le dire parce que d'après ce que j'ai
compris il était lui même en train
d'enregistrer son intervention donc du
coup ils étaient enfermés dans une pièce
et donc pendant un quart d'heure vingt
minutes au 10 mai quand est-ce qui va
l'annoncer quand est ce qu'ils valent
avancer parce que malgré tout quant au
fait un journal y avait beaucoup de
pages prévues pour un événement il en
faut beaucoup de pages pour un autre il
ya plein de de deux choses matérielles
qu'il faut régler et puis très vite
tourné eu aucune confirmation que le
discours de macro ont été reportés donc
on n'avait plus fait que d'une autre
dame et toute la nuit du notre-dame et
sur le web notre dame et sur la vidéo de
notre dame est sur le papier de notre
dame et puis une édition depuis deux
éditions plon montre le tirage et puis
on appelle l'imprimerie dans le sud est
puis enfin c'est à sceller les les
j'aurais envoyé quand même personne
n'avait hier soir on avait cinq ou six
personnes sur place qu'on a envie ou qui
sont allés dit spontanément qui nous
envoyait d'abord des petits éléments
pour le web puisque le fc se nourrit de
1000 témoignage que ce soit des photos
des tweets des taux qu'on avait arthur
verda qui fait de la politique on avait
de sophie de ravinel on avait des jeunes
du web qui étaient partis sur place qui
déçoit et tout ça et puis et puis au
bout d'un moment pour le print qu'est ce
qu'on fait et on reconstitue à partir de
ce qu'on a un sommaire et on fait le
journal de la première édition puis la
deuxième édition et toute la nuit ça
continue puisque en fait le web ne s'est
pas arrêté de la nuit et la vidéo à
tourner jusqu'à minuit et demi
maintenant et on recommence ce malgré la
dernière édition papier vos la boucle et
à quelle heure la bande à la mine nuit
ou 00h30 tôt quand on on est parti on
avait la vue depuis la une et deux pages
puis la vie des quatre pages